good morning John so when you told me
you were going to go to the United
Nations I was like oh my God that's a
lot of traveled right before Pizza Miss
like I was right but not as much as I
thought I was because I thought that the
UN was in Europe and finding out that
you were actually in New York City where
most of the organs of the UN are based
it was a surprise to me and made me
realize that I don't know uh very much
about what the UN is or what it does and
thus I'm definitely not qualified to
tell people what the U.N is or what it
does but that's not gonna stop me in
1945 the world had just shot guns at and
dropped bombs on itself for quite a long
time in a way that everyone hated
everyone's saying anyway and people were
like what if we like never do that again
so a bunch of countries got together and
they're like let's unite the Nations
we'll call it the United Nations except
of course we will not unite the Nations
nor will we have it actually be a goal
to unite the Nations we will just it's
like aim for the moon you might hit the
stars and the stars are not doing well
World War III the Nations will meet
anyway they'll come together in rooms
and decide what's okay and not and look
it has been a long time since we had a
World War so good honor so what will the
United Nations do and how will it
operate they asked well first we must
have six organs and we'll call them
organs because that's gross and I'm not
gonna get used to calling them organs
but organ number one the general
assembly which has every member state in
it but not every state is a member which
is contentious one of the things that
the general assembly does is it votes on
which states can become members and you
need a two-thirds vote for that to
happen and there are some states that
are like I would like to be recognized
and a lot of the world is like no
I don't think you we will so the general
assembly is when all the member states
are you know generally assembled and
they decide to do stuff like their main
things that they do is vote on whether
or not countries should be member states
they figure out the budget for the UN
how to spend the money and where the
money is going to come from and they try
to make peace happen just pay attention
to the lines we've drawn on the map if
it's not on your side of the line it's
not yours and you shouldn't shoot people
about it so yeah important stuff has to
pass with a two-thirds vote which is
tricky uh it makes it so that the UN
moves pretty slowly and I think that's
kind of by Design because when you're
dealing with like a whole planet you
don't want to make any mistakes that are
too big second organ is the security
Council it's like the beefiest organ I
didn't do this they did this
it's not my fault the security Council
has five permanent members that all have
veto power and then 10 other members
that don't have veto power that are
rotated in and out and the five members
with veto power are the ones who were
the big ones that won World War II they
kind of put themselves in charge it's
what I like to call the red white and
blue flag club plus China also the
Russian Federation the People's Republic
of China didn't even exist back then so
they weren't technically part of the
security Council but they sort of
inherited it because it's the same land
I guess what it generally makes me feel
is I'm glad I'm not in charge this all
sounds very complicated and the security
council's job is also to maintain peace
to just have there not be War uh which
is gets a little tricky when one of the
people with veto power is like but what
if I like did some War I can veto
anything that you would try to do to
stop me from doing the war that I'm
doing now I don't think anybody out
there is claiming it's a perfect system
so check this out laws aren't really
laws unless you have a way to enforce
the laws and when the general assem
assembly says stuff it passes what's
called resolutions and if a member State
doesn't want to do the resolution they
don't have to like the enforcement is
basically being like come on man you
said you would and now you aren't that's
not cool which isn't nothing like peer
pressure actually does kind of work in
diplomacy there's a lot of what
diplomacy is but what the security
Council says is actually international
law uh and if you don't do it you can
get sanctioned you can get blockaded you
can even have military intervention so
yeah Security Council is big deal third
organ the Hague which is the only one
that is not headquartered in New York
City Hague is headquartered in The Hague
which is the name of a city which is a
weird way to name a city with the first
but it's also in the Netherlands so I
guess that's I don't know is that how
they do it there it's actually not
called The Hague they call it the Hague
because it's in the Hague but it's the
international court of justice and it
settles legal disputes between countries
also prosecutes international law so
like those very chill folks who did
whole ass war crimes they get tried at
the hay the court has 15 judges none of
them can be from the same country as
another one they are appointed by like
votes from the general assembly and the
security Council and they have nine-year
terms because having lifetime
appointments for judges would be silly
right right fourth organ the Secretariat
which is not a horse it is a horse but
this is not a horse it's an organ and
the Secretariat is the organ that like
does stuff instead of just like talking
in rooms and making the rules it
actually does things like you like the
general assembly says we should do this
and the Secretariat is like okay I will
manage that with people who exist in the
world and do things they go and do
International Aid or they do
peacekeeping Mission the fifth and least
important organ is the trusteeship
council and I can say that it's the
least important organ because they did
it they finished their job and now it
just does like it's dissolved it doesn't
exist anymore great job the sixth organ
which is definitely not the least
important organ I didn't put these in
any like order except what's useful for
The Narrative of the script is the
economic and social Council this has
kind of become like the catch-all place
for doing things that need done from
women's rights to naming geographical
features like they do a bunch of stuff
one of the things inside is UNESCO
they're the people who do the world
heritage site so they're just like a
people who decide which places are the
most important which does sound like
kind of a fun job the U.N from what I
can tell and I cannot tell very much I
I'm not the guy to ask uh is a
deliberative and important body it does
a lot of things and like the different
things it does are administered
differently like the unhcr the high
Commission on refugees is run by both
the general assembly and the economic
and social Council other things are just
run by the general assembly other things
are run by organizations inside of
organizations inside of the economic and
social Council they have funds and
agencies and organs and bodies and those
are all different things and for clarity
lots of those things aren't based in New
York City like the main organs five of
the six are based in New York City but
there's they're all over the place it's
like it's like wildly complex and only
really makes sense to people who spend a
lot of time inside of it or have taken a
lot of time to learn about like I you
know it seems like normal how we do it
in the U.S but it's not it's also Arcane
and weird and complicated but it has
vital goals it does a lot of work and
its main goal of like blood please oh
God please let's not do world war three
has so far been accomplished which
considering that the time between the
end of the first world war and the
beginning of the second world war is
less time than Beyonce has been a solo
performer is a pretty big win it's
really amazing to me that you were on
that stage and that you took your chance
to say the thing that needed to be said
that the continued burden of
tuberculosis is a choice that we are
making the good news is that we can make
different choices and I know that
because we have made different choices
like here's a chart of deaths by age in
the world from 1950 to today here's a
chart of the burden of polio from 1980
to today and here's the death rate from
tuberculosis from 1990 to today and I
don't like this one as much as I like
the others but it also makes it clear
fear that we're still in the middle of
the story and we don't have to live with
the world as it is John I'll see you on
Tuesday